in 2003 a doctor flew to Hong Kong to
attend a wedding and he brought with him
a mysterious deadly virus that he had
caught from patients he was treating in
mainland China unfortunately the doctor
never made it to the wedding and he died
two weeks later but not before he had
infected several other people from
different countries who were staying on
the same floor of his hotel and within a
month this mysterious virus was wreaking
havoc and causing panic around the world
but where did this virus come from and
how did it spread around the globe to
solve this mystery we will construct an
evolutionary tree for similar viruses
from different species in order to
determine which species started the
epidemic studying viruses that cause
epidemics is just one of the many
applications of evolutionary trees which
range from catching criminals to
identifying the birthplace of human
civilization when we construct
evolutionary trees we use the genomes of
present-day species to get insight into
how these species have evolved from
their ancestor but can we reconstruct
the genes and proteins from extinct
species speaking of extinct species when
I was seven years old I saw the movie
Jurassic Park and it made me dream of
one day getting to see a real-life
dinosaur fortunately I am NOT alone
famous paleontologist Jack Horner has
the same dream and this shared dream of
ours took one small step toward reality
when in 2007 Horner and his colleagues
identified protein fragments that had
miraculously survived in a t-rex fossil
for 68 million years because these
proteins were very similar to chicken
proteins they presented the first
genetic evidence for the hypothesis that
birds had evolved from dinosaurs in fact
Horner was so inspired by this discovery
that he even published a book about how
researchers could one day genetically
modify a chicken into a real-life t-rex
but what in the world do algorithm--
to these dinosaur fossils it turn out
that since all Algar it's for protein
sequencing make errors
some scientists myself included the hope
due to whether Horner had really found
any evidence of t-rex protein but with
each side is correct we hope that you
will join us and decide for yourself
although these instructors may appear
crazy they are not quite as mad as they
look dr. Pavel PES Nair is a
distinguished professor of computer
science at the University of California
San Diego and a leading authority on
bioinformatics he's dressed this way
because he sometimes thinks that he's a
sheriff of bioinformatics a frontier
discipline underpinning the digital
revolution in biology and personalized
medicine dr. Phillip Campo is an
assistant professor of computer science
at Carnegie Mellon University to learn
why he is dressed this way you'll need
to take this course or read the textbook
bioinformatics algorithms and active
learning approach co-authored by the two
speakers